here's a real red flag President Donald
Trump has been urging world leaders to
call him on his cell phone if you know
anything about anything
you realize that that rage raises major
security and secrecy concerns who has
Trump's number we know that Canada's
Justin Trudeau has Trump's number and
has used it we know that Mexico's
president Enrique Pena Nieto has Trump's
phone we know that Frances new president
Emmanuel macron and possibly others have
Donald Trump's personal cell phone
number what's the problem with this well
it's not a secure communication you are
exposed to eavesdropping you're exposed
to surveillance there is a transparency
issue with this where there are no
transcripts or records of those calls
and it could be circumventing government
transparency by the way the government
transparency the Donald Trump prominent
promised would be the hallmark of his
administration Vlad how are you oh no
I'm not busy I'm just here at mar-a-lago
playing a round of golf with Rodrigo my
new buddy who's doing a heck of a job on
the war on drugs check out the cool
phone that Sergey kids lyac handed me in
the Oval Office
great for international calls it even
has a Moscow area code so calls to
Russia or local no roaming charges
pretty cool right how can Donald Trump
with a straight face criticize Hillary
Clinton for a private email server how
can you criticize Hillary Clinton for
her handling of sensitive information
when Trump is not only talking to world
leaders on his personal cell phone but
also just spilling secrets to Russian
diplomats and suspected spy recruiters
in the Oval Office
jeopardizing the safety of of ally
allied countries of operatives spilling
the location of nuclear submarines on
the phone with the Filipino President
it's inconceivable but this is what
we're dealing with and even
government-issued cell phones are
generally considered to be at risk of
eavesdropping by foreign
this is not as far as we know a
government-issued cellphone this is
Donald Trump's personal cell phone I
haven't started house of cards season
five yet which came out yesterday I'm
looking forward to it
but there's no way that season five of
house of cards could even approximate
the craziness of the real world right
now right I mean it's just inconceivable
that this is what we're dealing with in
2017 with the President of the United
States